on Monday we talked a lot about
variational inference and how to
optimize for uh
complex distributions of data and today
we're going to actually put some of that
into practice in the context of meta
learning algorithms and so specifically
we'll again try to motivate why we might
want Bayesian metal learning algorithms
in the first place then we'll talk about
different classes of Bayesian metal
learning algorithms including Black Box
metal learning algorithms and
optimization based algorithms
uh and then lastly we'll talk about how
to actually evaluate Bayesian meta
learning algorithms and how that differs
from the typical kind of few shot
learning evaluation that we've seen
previously in class
and so the goals for by the end of the
lecture are to try to be able to
understand
um the interpretation as metal of metal
learning as Bayesian inference and also
understand techniques for representing
uncertainty over parameters versus over
predictions
um so I guess also one quick disclaimer
like a lot of the class content this is
an active area of research and so there
are also yeah we'll be in some cases
potentially more questions and answers
in terms of the algorithms that we're
looking at but that's also true for for
a lot of the content we've seen in the
course as well
cool
um so let's start start by talking a
little bit about a recap of some of the
things that we've seen so far both in
terms of meta learning algorithms uh and
also in terms of casting that in the
context of Bayesian graphical models
and so when we covered uh
the kind of the last lecture in on metal
learning algorithms we talked about the
properties that we might want from a
metal learning algorithm
um
and specifically we were talking about
the properties of the inner loop of that
algorithm like the learning procedure
that it gives you so and there were two
different properties that we really
um focused on when talking about this
the first was thinking about the
expressive power of the inner loop of
that algorithm specifically can the
inner loop of that algorithm represent a
wide range of learning procedures
and the second was looking at the
consistency of that inner loop which was
consistency in the notion of statistical
consistency which is that if you give
the inner loop enough data can you
expect it to solve the task and reach a
consistent estimator of or give you a
consistent estimator of the task
specific parameters
um but and these properties are
important but one property that we
haven't talked that much about is the
ability to reason about uncertainty and
this is really the the focus of Bayesian
metal learning algorithms uh and by that
I mean the ability to try to reason
about ambiguity that might come up in
the learning process
and this is important in active learning
settings
um in settings where you want calibrated
uncertainty estimates as well as in
reinforcement learning settings and it
also gives us
um
one might argue kind of approaches that
are quite principled from the Bayesian
standpoint insofar as they're going to
be maximizing the likelihood under some
graphical model
um cool so
um now this will also be a little bit of
recap which is that
um
actually even before we started talking
about Metal learning algorithms we
talked about how training and testing
tasks should share some degree of
structure
and we talked about how this
can be thought of as a statistical
dependence on some latent information
Theta
and we brought up this graphical model
right here where we have our top
specific parameters Phi I and some
shared latent information Theta and we
also have the data that we can observe
which includes a support set denoted as
X tray and X and Y train here and a
query set denoted as x-test and Y test
here
um and we also talked about if we kind
of condition on the shared information
that means that the past parameters
become independent
uh and are not otherwise independent
from one another
and as a result if you condition on your
um on that shared information on Theta
that gives you information about Phi I
and so the kind of the distribution over
Phi I is going to have a lower entropy
it's going to have less Randomness
because we have some knowledge about the
shared structure across the different
tasks
um
and then I guess it's been a while since
we talked about this a little bit so I
guess we can maybe walk through these
thought exercises again so the first
thought exercise was that if you can
identify the meta parameters Theta
um such as with the metal learning
algorithm
when should you expect when should
learning Phi I be faster than if you
were to learn from scratch
does anyone have any thoughts
when your task is part of the same
distribution foreign
yeah so one example is if if your task
the the task that you're trying to learn
is from the same distribution as the
tasks that you saw during meta training
then the shared structure should be
useful for helping you infer what Phi I
should correspond to
any other thoughts
so one of the things that I think we
covered last time is that if the tasks
do share some structure then this data
is going to help you is basically going
to kind of reduce your uncertainty over
Phi whereas if the tasks are completely
independent from one another and don't
have an insurance structure then you
won't actually be reducing entropy when
you condition on the data a variable
[Music]
um
and then lastly we also talked about
this other case where
where if you condition on Theta
what happens if the entropy is zero
and this is the case where
Theta tells you everything there is to
know about the top specific parameters
in that case you don't actually need any
support set or any data to infer what
the top specific parameters are and in
this case you could actually think of
this a lot as memorization you don't
actually need the support set in order
to infer the top specific parameters and
so in this case your your metal learning
algorithm may just memorize all of the
tasks and not actually use the support
set
cool
um and then
kind of jumping into Beijing meta
learning algorithms all the algorithms
that we've seen so far use some give us
our task specific parameters in a fully
deterministic way
so they'll give us addition well they'll
give us a degenerate distribution over
5i because it'll just give us one uh one
parameter Vector they won't give us a
distribution that has any amount of
support to it
um and there are cases where we do
actually want to generate multiple
hypotheses and so this is an example
that we saw on Monday where future
learning problems might be ambiguous so
you might have
um a support set where it's inherently
unclear which attributes you should be
paying attention to
um and if we can learn to generate
hypotheses about the underlying function
then this can tell us if we need more
labels or if we should abstain from
making a prediction on a new example uh
because it's uncertain
and so this is important safety critical
settings where you want to decide if you
should make a decision Active Learning
settings and also exploration settings
in this specific example in this lecture
we will be talking about algorithms that
can actually handle the specific setting
and generate hypotheses into great
basically multiple classifiers one that
pays attention to the smiling attribute
one that pays attention to the wearing
hat attribute and one that pays
attention to the young versus old
attribute
cool
um so let's get into algorithms for
doing this
um now the first like v0 algorithm
that we could think about doing is uh
we've seen all of these algorithms that
give us kind of a label y test given a
support set and an input X test
and so what we could do is
have F output the parameters of a
distribution over y test
and in the classification settings that
we've done you've already been doing
that so we're not actually like
literally outputting one single label we
output the probabilities for each class
um and so
what you've been doing so far like in
the homework for example is to Output
probability values over a discrete
categorical distribution but you could
also output
um outputs on other distribution over y
test so in regression problems you could
output the muted variance
you could use a mixture density Network
like what we talked about on Monday
where you output the means variances and
weights for a mixture of gaussians over
y test
um or if you have something more
multi-dimensional you could have an auto
have kind of this output over y test be
a sequence of distributions such as an
auto regressive model
um
and then once you choose your
distribution class over y test then you
can just optimize
with maximum likelihood and that would
like maximum likelihood would correspond
to the outer loss of your meta learning
algorithm
so this is pretty simple
um and in fact we've already been doing
it
um and so this is nice you can combine
it with a variety of like different
metal learning algorithms
um but the downside is that you can't
actually
this will allow you to reason about
uncertainty over the label but it won't
allow you to reason over and about the
uncertainty of the underlying function
uh and
being able to reason about uncertainty
of the function is important if you want
to understand how to reduce uncertainty
across a set of data points
because it could be that you're very
uncertain about one data point and
you're in certain and if you had a label
for that data point that would help
reduce your uncertainty for a whole host
of other data points as well and so if
you had some notion about your
uncertainty of the underlying function
then you'll understand
basically how your uncertainty across
different data points relates to one
another
um and then another downside of this is
that you can really only capture a
limited class of distributions over y
test and this is actually a question
that came up after lecture on Monday
which is
like you can output like
um I've talked about how you could
output like immune variants of a
gaussian over white test and a
categorical distribution why can't we
just output some kind of crazy
distribution over y test that looks like
something like this
and the challenge that comes up here is
if you want to out if you want this to
be kind of your distribution over uh
your labels
given some input maybe also given your
support set
then you need to be able to parametrize
this distribution in some way
and parameterizing distributions like
this uh
ends up being very difficult we know how
to parametrize gaussians as a mean and
variance and we have a nice equation for
that given those two variables but once
you have more complex distributions it's
very difficult to parametrize that in a
way that is differentiable and is is
like a well-formed function
cool
um yeah and then the last thing that
I'll also mention is that generally if
you train a neural network with maximum
likelihood uh neural networks tend to
give you very poorly calibrated
uncertainty estimates
and by that I mean that if it if you
have a binary classification problem and
it gives you say like a 0.9 for one
class and a 0.1 for another class
uh oftentimes that doesn't mean that it
will be correct on this data point with
a likelihood of 0.9 oftentimes neural
networks tend to be
um
oftentimes they will generally tend to
be a little bit more overconfident
um but even then if you even if you like
scale down these probability values to
try to make them less confident you're
often able not able to get a
um an estimate that's actually
consistent with the probability that it
will be correct on the given data point
cool any questions up until here
the estimate of calibration right
because it's very subjective that should
be more than something
yeah so the question is how do we how do
we measure whether or not a neural
network is well calibrated and
there is there's a few different ways to
do it
um
I I'll skip ahead actually a little bit
to
um
one visualization here and
well so
yeah there's a couple different metrics
one metric is called the expected
calibration error but something that I
think is even more detailed is what's
called a reliability diagram and
what this is plotting is um the x-axis
is the confidence that the neural
network outputted and so over here it
would say that the confidence is a 0.9
and the x-axis is showing the accuracy
for all the data points that have a
confidence of that particular value
and ideally you would want this to be a
diagonal line where if you have zero
confidence you have zero accuracy if you
have 50 confidence you have 50 accuracy
and so forth and so basically this is
going to be looking at
how often do your do your confidence
measures actually match the likelihood
of getting it correct in practice
um and so the closer to this is to
um to a diagonal line the better your
calibration estimates are
yeah
uncertainty right like maybe there's
some true Elliot heart uncertainty like
it's impossible to know and that seems
like extended actors either kind of
setting would make pretty good as
defensive answer but then there's just
your model is wrong right it's not an
Elliot card thing it's just like people
are right and that's in the net he's
predicting a confidence interval or
prediction interval seems sort of like
asking just for a better model foreign
yeah so there's I guess first to kind of
make every make sure everyone's on the
same page there's actually two kinds of
uncertainty
um one is uncertainty arising from noise
in the data itself I can hear it like
there's just um some noise underlying
the like
um the kind of the data generating P of
Y given X and that's often referred to
as uh aliatoric uncertainty or I often
like to use maybe something like data
uncertainty which I think is a little
bit more clear and then there's a second
kind of form of uncertainty that's just
whether or not your model is making the
correct
um prediction and that's often referred
to as epistemic uncertainty
or or model uncertainty and this has to
do with um basically does your model
know what it doesn't know and
generally getting good estimates of kind
of the uncertainty in the data is easier
um because
the um you can basically just like look
at the data and look at the like the
frequency at which the label corresponds
to a particular value whereas it's much
harder to get a sense for what your
model doesn't know because that would if
you could do that then you could also
often get a better model by if you're
very confident that you're wrong then
you should just predict something else
rather than just confidently
saying I know I'm wrong and here's the
zero confidence estimate
um and so generally this kind of
uncertainty is much more difficult to
get
um but there are and especially with
with things like maximum likelihood
um there are some ways for
getting this kind of uncertainty and one
thing that we'll talk about a little bit
is using ensembles
uh and in general this is probably one
of the most effective ways to get
Notions of epistemic uncertainty but
that is uh they're still not very good
um and it is a little bit of a paradox
because if you could get really good at
uncertain Testaments then
um you would also just be able to
improve your model
cool
so
oh I had a thought exercise
um yeah so we've talked about how we can
just have our metal learner output a
distribution over Y and then train
things with maximum likelihood
um now my question for you is
instead of having to Output a
distribution over y uh can we have it
output a distribution over Phi
um given our Trading
data and then just train that with
maximum likelihood
does anyone have any thoughts yeah
yeah
so in order to do maximum likelihood on
this distribution you need the ground
Truth for Phi and we we have access to
ground truth labels but we don't have
access to ground truth files and so for
that reason we can't just do maximum
likelihood on this distribution in order
to get an estimate of the distribution
and so that's why we need algorithms
that are more interesting than maximum
likelihood algorithms
cool
um
and so to be able to create these kinds
of algorithms we can rely on the
probabilistic kind of deep learning
toolbox and
um we went into depth on
um on one form of of tool in the toolbox
which is latent variable models and
variational inference on Monday
um
and this is will kind of primarily focus
on using this tool for creating in
Bayesian Better Learning algorithms but
there are also other tools that we could
consider using and one tool that we will
briefly cover is using what's called
Bayesian ensembles
and the way that ensembles work is
instead of trying to explicitly
represent
um some distribution like output a mean
in the variants what it tries to do is
it basically tries to represent multiple
particles that are samples from that
distribution
and the way that you did do this is very
very simple oftentimes you just train
multiple separate models on your data
set
and by trading multiple models on your
data set with maximum likelihood that
will give you
um kind of multiple copies of your given
model
and it turns out that this um
oftentimes the model that you get will
be slightly different from one another
and that will give you basically samples
from your distribution
um there's also ways to make this uh
work even better and we'll also talk
about that a little bit
um
Beyond these first two things there's
also something called Bayesian neural
networks and the way that these work is
um basically just directly forming a
distribution over neural network
parameters and in particular usually a
gaussian distribution
and so instead of having a single neural
network with weights Theta you will have
a neural network with a a mean
for your weights and a variance for your
weights and that allows you to form a
gaussian distribution over
your the weights of your neural network
and of course if you represented a full
covariance Matrix over the weights of
your neural network then that would be
quadratic in the number of parameters
that you have and so that would not be a
particularly appealing choice and so
oftentimes we just pick a single
um
a single scalar variance value for each
of the weights and so
um you're just going to you'll have one
vector that's the same Dimension as your
weights which is Mu and another Vector
that's also the same Dimension as your
weights which is Sigma and that allows
you to get a fairly simple gaussian
distribution over weight space
and we'll be in this lecture we'll be
starting to see things that look kind of
like Bayesian neural networks where we
have where we are going to be forming
kind of gaussian distributions over over
neural network weights
um cool and then I mentioned this a
little bit on Monday but there's also a
couple other distribution classes such
as normalizing flows energy-based models
and Gans
um we're not going to really talk about
these today and for the most part people
haven't used these algorithms for
um in the context of Bayesian metal
learning but it means that the um these
other two
ways of representing distributions could
also be useful for developing new
Bayesian meta learning algorithms
cool
um
so now before we like I guess sort of
one more recap slide before we actually
start getting into Bayesian metal
learning algorithms is to try to recap
what we covered on Monday
um and on Monday we were talking about
uh trying to represent models represent
distributions using latent variables and
really the key idea is we're going to
have a simple distribution of our latent
variable Z we're going to then transform
that into our our example SpaceX
um and so our observed variables X our
latent variable is z and we formulated a
lower bound on the log likelihood and
there were a couple of different ways to
represent this lower bound the first was
to find was basically the expectation of
under Q of log P so basically trying to
find a latent variable value that has
maximum probability under P but then
also have an entropy term so that you're
covering the distribution accurately and
representing that distribution well
um and then the second interpretation
that we looked at was
um trying to have one term that's
basically trying to be able to
reconstruct examples from encoded latent
um along with a kale Divergence between
the inferred latent and the prior
and these two are equivalent and
optimizing or maximizing for this
objective on the right hand side is also
going to maximize the log likelihood in
turn
um
P corresponds to the model and P of x
given Z is represented with a neural
network P of Z is represented with a
standard normal distribution although in
practice you can also learn the prior as
well
and then
Q is the inference Network or the
variational distribution which is kind
of our approximation of the posterior of
Z given X
and if we want to sample from this model
at test time we often throw away our
inference Network and only use the model
p and in that sense it's often primarily
used as a tool for for doing inference
and for training the model
um we often use Theta to know the model
parameters and find it to note the
variational parameters
um and then the last thing that we
talked about was to actually optimized
for this objective we need to be able to
optimize with respect to the kind of
sampling distribution right here
um and the way that we do that is with
the reparametrization trick which
um basically allows us to re-parametrize
samples from a gaussian distribution as
the sum of the mean plus the variance
times Epsilon where Epsilon is an
independent random variable and this
allows us to actually optimize for the
parameters of that distribution without
um
um by kind of decomposing it into these
um into these two terms
cool
um and so another big question is if we
can use kind of ideas from here for meta
learning
um and so uh as we've uh sort of hinted
up we can
and so
in particular
um
in the context of meta learning
we
are going to have
um our observed variable
um in this case The observed variable
will now correspond to the data for a
particular task
um and so just like kind of when you go
from learning to meta learning you're
kind of treating these data sets as data
points and so kind of the analogy
continues there and then the latent
variable
will correspond to the Past specific
parameters Phi I
and once we've defined these two things
then we can basically just
um reuse everything from very racial
inference that we caught that we learned
about before where we can formulate
um kind of lower a lower bound on the
likelihood as
an expectation under Q of Phi
of log P of d i given Phi I
um minus the KL Divergence between
Q of Phi
and our prior over Phi
and so this is just basically
um rewriting everything on the
um kind of in our evidence lower bound
but kind of replacing our observed
variable with Di and our latent variable
with Phi I yeah
yeah so
the question was why are we not writing
Q as Phi given D
um so I wanted to write it first as this
because Q can really be conditioned on
anything
um as we talked about on Monday uh it
just needs to give you some estimate
over five and so we have a choice in
terms of what we might want to condition
Q on
um and so we we can condition it on Di
but we may also want to condition it on
something else uh and so
does anyone have thoughts on what we
might condition Q on
yeah
so the responses we maybe we want to
consider conditioning Q on the task or
the task representation
so what is the task representation
um
[Music]
yeah so one thing you do is condition it
on the training data set
um
and
this
um
and this would basically kind of
um it's always mimic what we saw before
and
um except that we're actually
specifically thinking about di train
here and the cool thing about this
particular choice is that you can think
of this as a neural network that takes
as input uh the training data set and
outputs
a distribution over Phi I
and
this starts to look a lot like what we
saw in Black Box meta learning where
we're training a neural network to take
his input a training data set and output
a set of parameters that solves that
training data set
and so in many ways you can think about
the kind of this kind of posterior
inference process as kind of the inner
loop of the metal learning algorithm
um now one other thing that I'll mention
here is that we want to Output a
distribution over over Phi I and so what
we'll actually do is
um we can model this as a gaussian
distribution and so this neural network
will actually output
um a mu and a sigma for Phi I
um and this will be kind of a lot like a
Bayesian neural network where
we're going to be having a kind of this
will represent a gaussian distribution
over the weights for task I uh and
this is going to be kind of twice as
large as the typical kind of output if
we were just outputting a single
parameter Vector because
um basically the kind of size of mu of
Phi is going to be equal to kind of the
size of our original space and similarly
our size over Sigma of Phi will also be
the same as the size of the parameter
vector
cool
um and then you can
I guess just to catch up a little bit on
the side so this is what we wrote down
before we thought about what Cue should
condition on and we can have q condition
on our training data
uh and then
we can view Q as the inner loop process
and then here when we actually are
optimizing for the likelihood under our
data for that for task I
um
what we can do is we can specifically
pick held out data for this such that
this is equal to log P of Y test I given
Phi I and X I test
and this will exactly correspond to what
we do in in the outer loop of the meta
learning algorithm where we evaluate how
good our neural network is Phi I on
making predictions for new
um new data points and so this will be
these will be sampled from the query set
um and so this is written right here
where basically the training data set is
used for the inference process and the
query data set is used
to evaluate the the likelihood of the
data under those parameters
cool
um and then the last question is
uh where do the meta parameters come
into play here
and uh the natural place for them to
come into play at least insofar as this
corresponds to Black Box meta learning
is right here
um where basically The Meta parameters
you can kind of view them as
parameterizing this network
um
Q
so this neural network has parameters
data
um you can also use them in other ways
as well so you can for example instead
of having
this
uh be just like a standard gaussian
distribution over parameters you could
actually learn a prior
over your parameters and so this would
correspond then to PFI given Theta
and this could be a good choice because
regularizing neural network parameters
towards a zero mean unit gaussian
distribution that may not correspond to
something that's like a very useful
set of weights for the network
um and so
if we introduce the the kind of meta
parameters in the inference Network and
the prior then the corresponding
equation looks like something like this
I should also mention that you could
also incorporate the meta parameters
into
the
function that's making predictions as
well
um in many cases we haven't done this
but if for example you're using an RNN
and there's kind of some weight sharing
between the meta parameters and the top
specific parameters then that would kind
of come into play here as well
um and so for completeness uh kind of
the final objective looks something like
this where we are
um we now have kind of a
you have some kind of sum over your
tasks I uh you're maximizing this
with respect to your meta parameters
and your
basically optimizing for how well your
task parameters solve the task
and also optimizing for your um
your inferred parameters or your kind of
your inferred distribution over the top
specific parameters matching some prior
distribution
yeah
because in something like mammal we
initialize the parameter and then we see
when we see examples we like Theta
binder sounds like a prior and then you
are updating a prioritization like the
belief or let's say the training
intercept and then is it like a good way
to think about like Theta as being a
prior for five
so the question was
um can we think of can we can we just
have PF I just B Theta
um
yeah so there's a few different ways
that you could parametrize this
um
you could basically just learn a um
basically have like learn a
a mu Theta and a Sigma Theta that you're
basically trying to regularize towards
[Music]
um
I wasn't quite sure how this relates to
mammal in this case we're purely looking
at is you can think of this as a pure
black box metal learning approach and
we'll talk about optimization based
metal learning approaches in a few
slides but
um
[Music]
so I was thinking that initializing the
parameters
[Music]
yeah so there
um in something like mammal it kind of
definitely intuitively makes sense to
actually think of theta as as a prior
like basically the initial parameters of
the prior and we'll cover that in a
couple slides
there's actually a way to formalize the
intuition too which is pretty cool
um cool so
once we formulate this objective we can
then kind of optimize it just like you
would optimize a variational autoencoder
um but uh instead of having your
inference Network be over some
representation space it's actually over
overweights
um
and
this allows you to represent
non-gaussian distributions over y test
because you now have a you're kind of
ultimately getting a distribution over
Phi I and then sampling from that
distribution
um and so
yeah it has a number of benefits this is
one benefit and it gives you a
distribution over functions rather than
um
rather than only a distribution over
your labels
because kind of at the end of this you
um
you you get some kind of estimates for y
test but you also are able to use your
inference Network to get a distribution
over top specific parameters
now on this note one thing that I should
mention is that uh
unlike in variational autoencoders where
you might throw away Q uh in this case
you won't you'll actually be using Queue
at test time
um if you want to basically infer like a
distribution of your top specific
parameters that's exactly what Q is
doing in this case and so uh the
interloop process is
um unlike in in variational autocoders
at test time you'll first use Q to get
Phi and then you'll use P to get a
distribution over your labels
um
now one of the downsides of this
approaches of this approach is that uh
you can only represent gaussian
distributions over Phi
uh and the reason for this is that
um
the things like the reparametrization
trick and kale Divergence
are primarily applicable to gaussian
distributions and if you want something
that is more expressive than a gaussian
distribution overweights then it is
difficult to apply this sort of
framework to that setting
um that said if you have a large enough
neural network especially a deep enough
neural network then the neural network
can kind of transform gaussian samples
um of gaussian Weights into
um something that ends up looking fairly
complex
cool
um so that was kind of version one of a
Bayesian metal learning algorithm and it
was a black box algorithm
now let's talk a little bit about
optimization based approaches
uh and there's
in in this case there's really kind of
one clear way to apply variational
inference to Black Box methods
um but for optimization based approaches
we're actually going to study
three different approaches uh to
Bayesian metal learning algorithms
um and before we actually talk about the
um those approaches let's talk a little
bit about simply just interpreting
optimization based meta learning as kind
of under a variational model
and in particular one intuition that
came up before is that uh if you're
running gradient descent
starting from some initial set of
parameter vectors or some of some
initial set of parameters
uh doing something like this
you can kind of intuitively think of
the initial parameters
as a form of prior
about the function that you're trying to
solve
um
and if you randomly initialize that
means you have no prior knowledge
whereas if you kind of initialize it
something that you think is pretty close
to to where you might want to go and you
only run a few steps of gradient descent
then that's going to strongly affect the
set of parameters that you end up with
and it turns out that you can actually
formalize that a little bit and so
um here's a graphical model that's
basically the same as um the one that we
saw before
it doesn't split up the train set in the
test set and it doesn't
um kind of separately represent X and Y
but otherwise it corresponds to the same
thing that we saw before
and if we're interested in maximizing
the log probability of the data
given our meta parameters you can expand
this out following the graphical model
to incorporate the latent variable Phi
where the log likelihood is equal to the
log product of the integral of P of D
given Phi and P of Phi given Theta
and then the last step
um
is one way that you can try to estimate
that integral so if you have this pretty
nasty integral over Phi that means
you're integrating over all possible
values of your task specific parameters
so we have P of uh d i given by I and P
of Phi I given Theta
D Phi I
um
one way that you could try to
approximate this integral
is basically try to find the Phi I uh
that has maximum probability
that's the thing that's going to have
the most weight
or basically have the largest term in
this integral
and you can very crudely estimate the
integral as just taking that map
estimate the thing that has the highest
probability and saying that this is kind
of roughly equal to
um
the uh
the value under the particular
maximum a posteriori estimate
oops no d5i
um and the reason why this is kind of
interesting to think about is that
there's a paper that shows in a very
simplified setting that gradient descent
with early stopping
corresponds to doing map inference
under a gaussian prior
with a mean at the initial parameters
and a a variance that depends on a
number of different factors including
like the number of gradient steps that
you run
and so what this means is that
um insofar as kind of that last line the
map estimate is approximating this
integral you can think of an algorithm
that runs gradient descent to get the
map estimate
as something that's approximating the
log likelihood
um and so if for example you run an
algorithm like mammal to get or write it
along with them like gradient descent to
get the map estimate and then optimize
for the likelihood of the data under
that map estimate which is what mammal
does
um that corresponds to the last equation
here
um and so the thing that's kind of cool
about this is it provides
kind of a Bayesian interpretation of
what the mammal algorithm is doing
although the thing that's somewhat
unsatisfying about this is it doesn't
allow us
to actually sample from the distribution
over toss parameters
um
it kind of allows us to interpret mammal
as a kind of a sort of evasion approach
but
it kind of almost gets rid of a lot of
like a the Bayesian part of Bayesian
approaches because it doesn't allow us
to actually think about this
distribution over top specific
parameters
um and so the next three algorithms that
we'll talk about are algorithms that
will allow us to actually sample from
this distribution rather than using a
map estimate
cool
um
so the first algorithm that we can think
about
um
it will start from
the algorithm that we derive in the
black box case
and
the only thing that will differ is our
choice of inference Network
and so before inference network was just
a neural network that took his input the
training data set and output some
parameters over a mean invariance over
our top specific parameters
and remember that the inference Network
Q this variational distribution it can
really be whatever you want it to be
and so one thing that you could do is
instead of having it be an inference
Network
like this
um you could actually kind of embed
gradient descent inside of queue
and so what it could look like is you
could take
um
start with some set of uh
some mean invariance I'll call this mean
invariance mu Theta and Sigma Theta
and then what Q could correspond to is
kind of running gradient descent with
respect to Mu Theta and gradient descent
with respect to Sigma Theta in order to
get
mu Phi I and Sigma Phi I
and you could have this
um
this kind of gradient descent process
corresponds to your inference Network
queue
and in particular these gradients will
be with respect to mu and sigma kind of
with respect to the loss for the
training data d traini
um so Q can be an arbitrary function and
instead of having QB and neural network
it could include a gradient operator
inside of it
um and so what you can do is have q
correspond to SGD on the mean and
variance of some neural network weights
with respect to D train I
um and so in this case uh the
this will give you a kind of immune and
and sigma over Phi I uh and kind of once
you define this inference that work like
this uh you can
kind of again reuse all of the same kind
of training procedure that we saw before
actually
we previously
now it's because
yeah so instead of being a neural
network that outputs a distribution it
will be a process that that still yields
a distribution
um the
this process does still have some
parameters specifically it has kind of
the initial mu and sigma and I called
these kind of mu Theta and Sigma Theta
kind of in that they sort of signify the
initial set of parameters that we saw in
an algorithm like mammal
any other questions
cool so
the only thing that changes we're using
kind of the same objective as before
we're just redefining the inference
Network to have a different form and
this form is analogous to the kind of
thing that we saw in optimization-based
metal learning algorithms where we're
basically just stuffing gradient descent
inside of our inference Network and
actually having gradient descent
correspond to
um what happens inside the other thing
that's
um that's different about optimization
like kind of a standard mammal algorithm
is that our meta parameters now are
going to correspond to both mu and sigma
here and so we'll have uh we won't just
have a kind of a single Theta Vector
we'll have two of these Theta vectors
one that corresponds to the mean and one
that corresponds to the variance
um
now the cool thing about this is that at
test time once we want to do inference
to infer our task specific parameters
we're just going to be running gradient
descent at test time so instead of doing
inference by passing it through a neural
network to get our task specific
parameters or our distribution over the
top specific parameters we're going to
be running gradient descent this means
that we should be
um kind of a little bit more robust to
tasks that are a little bit out of
distribution at test time
um the downside of this is that we are
um similar to before going to end up
with a gaussian distribution over our
top specific parameters
and this means that if we wanted to
represent a more complex distribution
over our top specific parameters uh we
would be out of luck in that case
and it's again kind of important for it
to be gaussian for two reasons one that
allows us to evaluate the KL Divergence
in closed form and second
um it allows us to use the
reparametrization trick to back prop
into this so would we
um when we sample from Q uh when we
sample a 5 from Q we're going to be
sampling a Phi from a gaussian
distribution parametrized by mu Phi and
um
and Sigma Phi
and we can again use the same kind of
reparametrization trick and have this be
equal to Mu Phi plus Epsilon times Sigma
Phi where Epsilon is sampled from
a uh a gaussian with mean zero and unit
variance and by making this a gaussian
distribution that allows us to use this
read parameterization trick and back
prop into
um into mu Phi and sigma I but also
backdrop all the way back into mu Theta
and Sigma Theta
yeah
it doesn't that's interesting but I just
wanted to control yeah so the question
was um in general an optimization based
meta learning The Meta parameters can
correspond to not just the
initialization but other things like the
learning rate and so forth and yeah that
also fits well into this framework so
um here I'm writing kind of mu Theta and
Sigma Theta as the main meta parameters
but you can also optimize
um other things and so for example you
could optimize the learning rate here
and have that be a part of the meta
parameters as well
foreign
so then there's a question of whether we
can model a non-gaussian posterior and
we'll look at two different approaches
for doing this
um the first is will be to use ensembles
and a particular
what we can do is if we want to get a
kind of a distribution over Phi I
uh we can basically just train an
ensemble of mammals uh and specifically
just train
M independent mammal models
train them independently with different
mini batches of tasks and so forth uh to
get an ensemble of mammals
and um it's also worth noting that you
can use ensembles with kind of black box
or non-parametric methods as well and
this will also give you
um
with some sense of distribution over
meta parameters and so this will give
you a distribution over meta parameters
and then when you run gradient descent
starting from those initializations
you'll also get a distribution over Phi
I
um
one challenge with ensembles is that if
you just train independently oftentimes
training will result in a set of
parameters or meta parameters that are
very similar to one another
and
one approach for dealing with this is to
try to more actively diversify the
weights that you get
um and try to kind of optimize for a
more diverse Ensemble of mammals
and so the way that this could work is
um there's actually a kind of a rather
than just kind of crudely trying to say
oh the the parameter Vector should be
independent
um there's something called Stein
variational gradient descent uh that
actually
actively pushes particles away from each
other with a particular choice of Kernel
and so the way that this method is going
to work is when we run gradient descent
in the Inner Loop we are not just going
to run gradient descent on our on our
support set
so
typically we'll do something like Theta
minus Alpha grad Theta L of
Theta with respect to D trade and then
this will be kind of this will
correspond to Phi I
and what we're going to do that's a
little bit different is we're going to
say that we want
[Music]
um
we want Phi I to be kind of different
from
the other members of our ensemble
and so we're going to optimize for
multiple kind of
multiple particles and so I'll use M to
denote the kind of the particle number
and we're going to additionally have a
term that
um
that says that we want
we want to kind of push away the value
of our parameters and make it different
from other values and so we can measure
kind of this the diff or the distance
between our current parameters that
we're optimizing and the uh
the values
the kind of the other particles that are
different for like M Prime dot equal to
M uh for that particular task
and so this is what the inner loop is
going to look like
um and then the outer loop will be
basically just the same as before the
equations here are just copied from the
paper and so they use slightly different
notation but the outer loop is just
going to correspond to
um optimizing for the likelihood of
Phi I on the
um
on the test set for task I and you're
going to be doing this for all of the
different parameters and so you're going
to sum over both the tasks I as well as
The Ensemble members
cool and so the only thing really here
that's changing is first that we're
going to be optimize we're going to have
kind of multiple particles that we're
optimizing for in the Inner Loop and
we're going to push them apart by adding
this additional term in our inner loop
objective yeah foreign
yeah the question is what kind of
kernels are most useful here I can
actually remember exactly what they used
in the paper here I think that typically
something just like a
um
looking at the like euclidean
distance is reasonable here I do think
that distances in parameter space are
not always a good function of
kind of functional similarity because
you can if there are some parts of the
weight Vector that are just not used by
the network then you can push those
parts away a lot and just kind of ignore
the other parts and that will lead to
two functions that are very different in
weight space but are identically
functionally and so you want your kernel
to to try to pay attention to all of the
parameters in the parameter Vector to
try to prevent that case
um and
if you can measure some notion of
functionality for example looking at
something like the Fisher information
Matrix or something like that then that
may lead to better performance but those
measures often end up being
computationally expensive or accrued
estimates of something that's
computationally expensive
um so you're saying that what happens at
meta test time might be different or
so at meta test time you actually also
run the same inner loop as well
um and so you
basically what you want to happen is
you'll have this kind of a single set of
initial parameters and you'll want to
try to like
have this lead to multiple
um
task specific parameters for that task
and this will basically
represent samples from p i of theta
given
um P sorry Pi or P of Phi I given Theta
and D train I
and so just like before we were
on the Whiteboard that's behind it um we
were getting the sort of distribution
with our inference Network in this case
we're representing this distribution
with um these different kind of samples
or these different Ensemble numbers
cool
um so the benefit of this sort of
approach is it's pretty simple to
implement
um it tends to work pretty well uh
ensembles especially are are one of the
most effective methods for model
uncertainty or epistemic uncertainty
and it also can give you non-gaussian
distributions like the the Phi eye that
you end up with
these could be samples from a
distribution that's much more complex
than a gaussian distribution
um the downside is that you do need to
maintain M different model instances and
this can get pretty expensive at times
but one way to try to mitigate this is
to do gradient based to do gradient
descent only on the last layer and then
you only have to maintain M different
copies of the last layer rather than M
different copies of the entire network
cool
um now from there we'll cover one more
Bayesian meta learning algorithm which
tries to give us kind of a non-gaussian
distribution over all of the parameters
in a way that's a bit cheaper than
maintaining M different copies
um
and some of the intuition behind this
last approach is to try to sample
parameter vectors with the procedure
that looks a little bit like hamiltonian
Monte Carlo
and the way that hamiltonian market
Monte Carlo works is you typically kind
of First add noise to your parameters
and then run gradient descent on your
parameters in order to typically
actually iterate that process in order
to ultimately
um draw samples from some distribution
and
kind of some of the intuition behind
this is we
um we're going to try to learn a prior
where
if we kind of randomly kind of Kick the
parameters or randomly add noise to the
parameters that will put us in different
modes of the distribution
um and so if we think about the kind of
example that we talked about before
where different attributes would
correspond to different classifiers
for example if we wanted to learn a
classifier for smiling or wearing a hat
versus a classifier for smiling and
young
um we'd like to learn a prior Theta
where if we add noise
um in One Direction it puts us in kind
of one Basin and if we add noise in the
other it kind of puts us in a different
mode
and so
um ideally we'd like to be able to learn
a Theta such that if we add noise and
then run gradient descent we'll get
different
um
different samples from this distribution
that end up being
classifiers that are that correspond to
like these different modes of the
distribution
um so that's the kind of high level
intuition in terms of how we might
actually do this
um
first we're actually going to have a
distribution over our meta parameters
this is going to be different from the
things that we saw before before we just
had a single Vector of meta parameters
that were basically parameterizing our
prior and our inference Network
and here we're going to actually also
have a kind of a distribution over these
meta parameters
and then we're going to also have a
distribution of Phi I given Theta
um and their goal will be to sample from
the posterior of Phi I given the support
set and the test example
we'd like to also be able to
sample from this distribution without
the test example so in practice we can
observe the test example
um and that distribution up there
corresponds to kind of inferring Phi
from everything that we can observe
although in practice it'd be nice if we
had kind of a single parameter Vector
that worked well for any Test example
not just the test example that is
observed at any given point in time
and then from there we can write down
our distribution over Phi I as
again kind of the product of P of theta
P of Phi I given Theta and then P of Y
train give an X train and Phi I and then
of course
um in this case integrating out Theta
so this is just the product of the the
distributions that underlie this
graphical model
um but of course uh this integral like
many of the other integrals that we've
seen in the class is completely
intractable because it has to integrate
out over
um over like kind of all the parameters
in this gaussian distribution
and so the last way that we're going to
try to deal with an intractable integral
in this case is um
is trying to crudely estimate this
distribution right here of Phi I given
Theta and X train y train and if we did
know this distribution then sampling
would be much kind of inferring Phi I
given X strain a y train would be much
easier because what we could do is we
could first sample Theta and then sample
from this distribution right here
um we can just and that's that's what's
called ancestral sampling where you
sample one and then sample from the next
distribution and it'll basically
transform our graphical model into this
one where you first sample from Theta
and then we sample from the distribution
that um feeds into Phi I
and that would give us a sample from
um the kind of distribution of P Phi
given X train and Y train
now of course we don't actually know
this distribution of PFI I given Theta
and X train y train
but what we could do is we could try to
estimate this as a map estimate just
like we saw in the kind of Bayesian
interpretation of mammal when we first
started talking about optimization based
Bayesian metal learning algorithms
um and the map estimate
um is a crude estimate of this
distribution it's only giving you the
mode of this distribution rather than a
sample from the distribution
but it's also a very convenient
approximation to this distribution
because once we have this um this
approximation then we can just
um then it's very easy to sample from
TFI
um and in particular
once we approximate this with map
inference and specifically with a few
steps of gradient descent
then at test time what happens is
we
will
basically first sample from Theta
and then to sample
then next we want to sample from
P of Phi given Theta and d i train
and to do this we'll then kind of take
the sample that we took
um and then kind of very crudely
approximate this as running gradient
descent starting from the sample maybe
I'll denote this as Theta Prime just to
differentiate from P of theta
um and then we're going to run gradient
descent
um
on di trade in this kind of corresponds
exactly to the procedure that we saw on
the previous slide where we first sample
and then run gradient descent
um and then
sampling is easy what about training you
can also actually just train this with
amortized variational inference I'm
going to skip the exact training
procedure for the sake of time but if
you're interested in learning more you
can talk about in office hours or you
could take a look at the paper
um and so kind of again
um kind of sampling from P of theta and
then running great descent looks like
what we talked about before
in particular sampling from P of theta
corresponds to
um basically taking mu Theta and then
adding noise corresponding and
multiplying that noise by the variance
and so that will correspond to basically
adding noise to Mu Theta
and then step two corresponds to running
gradient descent which will
kind of hopefully get us into these two
modes of the distribution or or
ideally more than two just two modes of
the distribution if we have more
ambiguity than that
do you have a question
so what do you mean by like keeping us
twice
right so the question is
um does this mean that we're keeping two
copies or read or are we doing the
process twice
um so
yeah so if we
our goal is really to sample from
um PFI kind of sample from be able to
sample multiple different top specific
parameters and the way that we'll do
that is we will just repeat this process
multiple times depending on the number
of samples that we want and so
if we want to see
um
if we think that there might be well
yeah it basically just corresponds to
the number of samples that you want
um you might start by like collecting
like five samples for example by adding
noise and then running gradient descent
and repeating that five times to get
five different classifiers
uh and if you see that you have a lot of
variance among your five different
classifiers then you could continue to
sample other classifiers
um from there
um the upside of this is that it will
give you a non-gaussian posterior it's
um fairly simple at test time you just
add noise and run gradient descent you
also only need to train
um
one one model instance the downside is
that it leads to a more complex training
or meta training procedure
yeah
because because
[Music]
yeah so to sample multiple to generate
multiple samples from Phi you'll sample
multiple thetas and run gradient descent
from each of those datas
instance
oh sorry you only need one meta training
model instance whereas when you train an
ensemble of mammals you'll need um kind
of multiple copies of the meta
parameters
cool um so to summarize all the methods
that we've talked about uh
v0 was just to Output a distribution
over y test which is simple
but it can't reason about uncertainty
over function space and then all the
methods that we talked about after v0
were actually giving us distributions
over classifiers or distribution over
predictors
um we talked about a black box approach
that used kind of a latent variable
model over Phi with amortized
variational inference and this allowed
us to represent non-gaussian
distributions over y but was restricted
to gaussian distributions over Phi
um and then we also talked about three
different optimization based Metallurgy
algorithms the first was just to kind of
stuff gradient the set into our
inference Network and this was pretty
simple it was a very simple modification
of the Black Box approach but it meant
that PFI given Theta had to be modeled
as a gaussian
we also talked about an ensemble which
is pretty simple make a model
non-gaussian distributions but requires
multiple model instances and then
um
the kind of the more hybrid approach
that we talked about that was combining
this map estimate and variational
inference can give you a non-gaussian
posterior but involves a more complex
trading procedure
in the last five minutes I'd like to
talk a little bit about evaluation of
these approaches
um
one thing that you could consider doing
is to try to use standard benchmarks
like mini imagenet or Omniglot and these
are standardized and have real images
and they're a good check that your
Bayesian metal learning approach didn't
break the metal learning algorithm that
you had before
uh
but they aren't really the best metric
of how good your Bayesian metal learning
algorithm is
um first metrics like accuracy won't
evaluate whether your uncertain
Testaments are calibrated and
second the tasks may not actually
exhibit that much ambiguity and so it
may not stress test your ability to
actually model distributions over task
parameters
um and then lastly it may also be that
uncertainty just isn't useful on those
data sets and it's good to actually
evaluate algorithms and settings where
they might be practically useful
um so what about better problems in
metrics so it really depends on what you
might care about
um so one thing that you could look at
that is uh that I think is kind of nice
because you can actually just visualize
the functions that it's learning is to
look at
um some ambiguous problems in like one
or two dimensions and actually visualize
the functions that it gives you
um so this is a few shot regression
problem where the purple triangles
correspond to the support examples
and
um
the the tasks correspond to either
sinusoids or linear functions and some
of the toaster is very little ambiguity
um and other tests there's actually a
lot more ambiguity so the middle
function for example is something where
um it could actually correspond to
either a linear function or a sinusoid
and you see that the the kind of the
process that samples these functions
will actually give you sometimes give
you linear functions and sometimes give
you sinusoidal functions
um you could also formulate an ambiguous
classification task this is a setting
where all the tasks corresponded to
these circular decision boundaries and
the algorithm is actually only given one
example in the support set just one
positive example that's indicated by
um the green plus sign
and that green plus sign may be anywhere
within the decision boundary and you see
that these dashed lines are showing the
decision boundaries corresponding to the
functions by I that you're sampling and
you can see kind of visually that it's
giving you a fairly diverse sample of
these functions
um so this is one kind of toy
visualization that gives you a lot of
um gives you the ability to kind of
interpret what's going on but it's also
very toy
um another thing that you could look at
is trying to generate uh trying to look
at ambiguous generation tasks so this is
something where the goal is to learn a
generative model over different
viewpoints of an object and it's given
only one uh one Viewpoint in the support
set which is shown on the left and the
goal is to generate lots of other
viewpoints which is shown
um in the middle of the slide
um and here you can actually just look
at the the samples in comparison to a
cvae this Asian metal algorithm called
Versa which is a lot like the black box
approach that we talked about is much
better able to
um kind of generate samples uh from the
distribution
and it also gives you
um kind of a lower mean squared error
and a lower ssim which is another
measure of reconstruction error
or sorry actually a higher ssim which is
you want to be higher on ssim metrics
um a third thing that you could look at
is looking at both accuracy as well as
mode coverage and likelihood
um and so you can take this love egg
task that we saw earlier where they're
kind of purposely ambiguous
some tasks basically kind of support set
is not enough information to figure out
what the positive examples and negative
examples should be
and um
there's a number of metrics that you can
look at in combination one is just
accuracy on classifying new examples but
you can also look at you can also
measure like there's three possible
classifiers for it to consider that are
kind of in this case visualized
um in B and you can try to see is it
learning all three of those classifiers
and we see in this example
um
the kind of the
um everything with the pink box is
showing things that were classified as
positive by the classifier and you can
see that it does actually give you three
classifiers that more or less in this
case cover the three
um kind of ground truth classifiers
underlying that data and you can also
look at kind of average negative log
likelihood yeah
there's maybe more than one dimension of
uncertainty like there are lots of ways
that you could be uncertain about
whether your image is right and are
there interesting trade-offs they're
like do these models have different
for the uncertainty
um so the question was the like there's
multiple possible dimensions of
ambiguity in tasks like this and are
there different trade-offs that models
can make
um
I
I guess
I do think that different algorithms
will have different properties
um
I certainly think that there are like
things like Versa are kind of strictly
better than cvae in this case
um
I haven't I don't know of any kind of
examples off the top of my head of kind
of interesting trade-offs between
algorithms but
um I can think about it and yeah
yeah
absolutely and one of the things I
actually wanted to provide in these
slides is that sometimes the numbers
they don't actually tell you that much
about what's actually going on and so
actually making these kinds of
visualizations I think is really helpful
for understanding
um kind of what's beyond the number
basically
um and
I guess it's also I think useful to be
kind of creative about the numbers that
you measure because
um
when you do it look at the data and kind
of notice different things you can try
to actually come up with metrics like
coverage like what are the kind of
number of classifiers that you're
representing that do actually capture
the kinds of things that you might want
to see
um and I guess in
um in this example it is actually
possible to get kind of classifiers that
have very low coverage but pretty high
accuracy and likewise things that have
really good coverage but slightly lower
accuracy and that is one example of a
trade-off that you can make depending on
kind of the hyper parameters of the
algorithm
cool um and the last message second to
last one is reliability diagrams which
you actually already talked about
um and the last thing you can look at is
active learning settings which is if you
give it if you allowed to actively query
a few additional data points how much
does the accuracy drop or sorry how much
does the error drop and how much does
the accuracy increase
um and you can see that uh kind of
Bayesian metal learning algorithms
um some like some of the ones that we
saw today are able to kind of drop the
error rate and increase the accuracy
faster than an algorithm that
um that kind of chooses data points at
random or an algorithm that doesn't have
good estimates of uncertainty
cool
um so yeah that's it for today uh we
talked about Bayesian metal learning
algorithms and kind of techniques for
representing uncertainty over parameters
um next week we're going to talk about
domain adaptation and domain
generalization which is a pretty cool
special case of kind of the multitask
and meta learning problem setting
um the following week we'll kind of have
our last kind of I don't know main
technical lecture I guess on lifelong
learning and then we'll start to have
two guest lectures and kind of a final
lecture on kind of open problems and
future directions
um before that last week we're going to
have Thanksgiving so we can eat some
turkey and
um yeah as a reminder homework 3 is due
on Friday